what makes you different is what makes
you spider-man
my name is Peter Parker I'm pretty sure
you know the rest I saved the city fell
in love then I saved the city again and
again and again look I'm a comic book
serial I get a Christmas album and it's
so so popsicle but this isn't about me
not anymore
spider-man swings in once the day's zip
zap zop in his little mask and answers
to no one I love you morons
dad are you serious I wanna hear it I
love you dad I love you got a car
[Music]
my name is Miles Morales
I'm the one and only spider-man at least
that's what I thought yeah be here for
supercollider
you gotta love this dimension you're
like me that's impossible
all right kids listen up this part is
your universe
soggy it's weird it's gross and this
delicious normal fry is my universe so
you want to learn to be spider-man
Keeney teach me yes I can time to swing
good doing it
double tap Turley's and quit it out
again whip and release your natural quit
[Music]
hey guys who are you I'm Gwen Stacy I'm
from another another dimension how many
more spider people are there hey fellas
this could literally not get any weirder
it can get weird okay we need to get
back to our universes soon
Brooklyn is gonna collapse my family
lives in Brooklyn whoa what's wrong
whether your city
it's mine
if I don't destroy the collider none of
us will have a home to go home to
remember what makes you different let's
go
is what makes you spider-man
officer I love you wait
[Music]
that way that way other way other way
other way other way do animals talk in
this dimension cuz I don't want to freak
him out
[Music]
[Applause]
you